доброго дня шановний колеги я рада
батчат і тут
усіх наших побратимів
в тому штук ви могли рухати українську
свиту вперед ми сьогодні цілий день буду
йому говорити про до централізації або
нас правді я централізація цілий сам
механізм
механізм заради були клімат і для нас
важливі бою і це
куди їдь сьогодні україна і
української suspense ву та української
свято
ми зрубав асв європейський демократичний
вибір і ми б ви не суперечки ти для наших
дітей зі своїми українці про святі
всьому жила його стін і шанси оби-ван і
учу вали сцб оснащені ми
знань та компетентність всі ми люди на
20 великих столиків
ми знаємо про наскільки ірисно магнітну
е наш окраїна ми знаємо про нас кільки
туризму з можливістю сьогодні території
і громади алла для нас важливо його
швидкість статус децентралізації як
шансам пофарбовані нісенітниця про потужність
сьогодні ми презентували і зараз
та умовляв і концепцію нової
української школи
ціни просто теоретично
porsche краще танець же прийнятий
новий закон про асвіту їм відсікаємо а б
у парламенті його глянув цю кінсі
руку в друга мучить вони і ми сьогодні
розумі
але що нам спожив він вогненний з миски
свити
а нові не розумом і порушення та школа по
будова на на засадах партнерство з
партнерству mesh вчителям та бочкам та
враховані та головне школа мої стати центром
громади та сама школа як центр
громади та їм us нову успішну
децентралізації для нас тут у ківі не
потрібно чистку та правильно утиліти потреби
шкірні дитинки та умова її навчання там
дивана ведмедик і сам цьому
про свято та функцію грамот і ми за розруху
і муся до чудського раз ходила повно
важливий коли us and we міністерству з цією
наукою ви спочатку лізу та політику та
форму і разом про свиту тримаючи поза
стандарт його почту улову спочатку
і витку вид на реалізацію тіла з місту
форму і ти ви
форму і ти у громада битий цього ми
готові з приємною вам у розвитку на
основі державної та локальних us with них
політик які будуть ворог про висновок і не
цілий ринок брати і ваші потреби
великі так децентралізації та створи не
опорних kill
був для нас першим уроком мис творилося
142 упор не школи до уроку це було 53
манула за крима так вже й пивним і
вливанням з державного бюджету 600
мільйонів гривою на автобуси на засідках
фінський фінансово не я і 300 мільйонів
гривень на про зносини затятих
будемо все продовжу water у буде і надалі
на 2017 рік ми вже перед badge йому через
механізм субвенції
300 миль uni у на зносі кабінету у
школах 200 мільйонів на закупив you
автобусі та 300 мільйонів гривень.
для об'їздних територіальних громад
ми хочемо з підлоги коти об'єкта негром
територіальні громади but і прикладом
ефективних us with них см
натиснули 142 опорний шкіл вище 20 bull та
ініціативою вузли за топ то ініціативу
об'єднаних територіальних громад
а 124 це було і не цвіт його зверху і
одягу та обласному державному
адміністраціям які в мили з рубає і
з творив і такі упор не школи там
daddy ти зможеш дугу ватою які смішно
свиту я хочу сказати що у нас le duc
цирк років у нас зменшило сокет з
дітей на індивідуальному на іржання кібли
фактичну та заливання вид нормального
навчання в нормальних умовах а зарости
гіти до возяться в такі упор не школи
перед нами багата робота шлях
децентралізації які всього нового од
тернистим шляхом і реформа про почет так
вже складно
олег шум і будемо акумулювати і свої
зус і я ми будемо атр йому в цій знаєш
але червоний результат я одягаюсь htc та
форум дозволити дати відповіді набагато
зап це не для кожного хто суди приїхавши
зацем і вид виведені я хочу скоро
статусу на воду і що поляку ось їх усім
вам заспі проти іпотеку ось і нашим
партнерам з реалізації цілей реформи
шведську українському проекту Петро ім до
децентралізації в Україні
міжнародному фонду відродження crispr
і я і популяризації реформи та відвари
всім партнером який не байдуже до того
що виглядає в Україні і я кипу
дають нам сьогодні руку допомогу ши раше
розквітаю з і куплені брати дякую